you know a lot of [ __ ] and like you've
clearly packaged this in really easy to
understand ways it's almost exhausting
listening because it's like every it's
like when you read a really good
historical book or something it's like
every sentence is packed with a fact
you seem like a grinder when you were
building these businesses were you just
like doing 80 hour 100 work weeks and
what about now because you're like
yolked you're huge you're like a
bodybuilder so so like how did you
balance like being fit and getting
married and you but i don't know you
well but you seem like you'd be grinding
hard so my wife works in the business
with me so we are true 50 50 partners
like it's very rare i like i recognize
how rare it is she actually is 100
matched with me and like should just as
much be on this call because she runs
the other half like she from a work
standpoint she has more output than i
did she is the operator so she builds
the infrastructure she does the
recruiting she sets the they are the hr
stuff she does the culture she like she
does i mean she runs everything um i
just you know occasionally come up with
a good idea and try and stick with it
long enough um to see it come true but
in terms of grinding like i love
business like i love this and there's
nothing that really stimulates me like
this and so i do as much of it as i can
and if we want to go out to dinner we'll
go out to dinner you know but like worst
i was just saying we're single so we
don't have kids and so we work from like
five-ish to four and then you know
usually in the middle of the day we'll
probably go to the gym for an hour or
two and then come back and keep working
and go out to dinner at night and that's
that's kind of our lives you seem pretty
um this isn't i would say i'm a little
bit i'm i'm definitely this sean has a
little bit of it too like manic's not
the right word but like neurotic maybe
is a better word um where it's like uh
there's something that's deep rooted
inside of you it's not like you want to
do something necessarily it feels like
you're it's more compulsive or obsessed
you're obsessed about stuff which i am
as well if that's true what's that
rooted in what are you trying to get
done so i think originally the drive was
from just crippling insecurity and
needing approval right and then i think
from like a behavioral conditioning
standpoint i got immediate feedback that
was positive and then i was conditioned
to continue those actions now i continue
to do them without the original catalyst
that got them going to begin with i
don't think i suffer you know from the
insecurities as much as i used to i'd
say i'm probably 30 better than i was at
the beginning and it might just be
because i have this massive big pile of
money that i can use as an emotional
crutch to why i'm not a piece of [ __ ]
that would help i'm just being like i
mean and if it were all disappeared i'd
find out how much actual growth i had or
if i just compensated by circumstance
and you know compensate for the division
yeah i don't know you can send it to me
and we'll we'll find out we'll see
let's run the experiment
i like so there's the compulsion and
like this last year i pretty much took
off like i did not work that much and so
i saw the difference and i have come to
accept that i love working and i don't
need to judge myself for that or or take
in other people's judgment on how much i
should quote do like this is my life and
this is what i like doing and their
ideals that they've arbitrarily made up
as what they define as balance are
irrelevant to me you said you took last
year off what'd you do what'd you get up
to um we traveled a lot uh went to cabo
went to scottsdale went to sedona went
to flagstaff traveled all over one out
felt felt honestly pretty empty like you
can only eat so many times like there's
just not a lot to do it feels good
having that rest though like you can't
be in the trenches i think like or
rather you need breaks from being at war
i think and maybe even phrasing it i'm
just throwing this out there like
phrasing it is instead of a like a break
is a shift in how you're thinking
because like it's going from dirt to
clouds but i still think it's high
leverage activity you know i mean or
like output it's just a different type
of output you said something on one of
your videos that uh you're one of the
only other people that i have heard say
this phrase i use it a lot which is yeah
i had a season like or this season i'm
doing this or i had a season where i was
really just focusing on x and that's
been like a game changer for me my
personal trainer and kind of coach she's
like my mindset coach plus trainer he
does this all the time but he's like
he's like i'm in a season right now
where i'm i'm just uh he'll be like you
know i'm practicing not waiting and he's
like he comes up with these little
themes or he'll be like right now i'm in
a season where i'm going to eat whatever
i want and it's kind of like in the
entrepreneurial world it's like time
boxing's like all right i'm going to
give myself two hours to get this [ __ ]
[ __ ] done or i'm going to launch in the
next two weeks no matter what right like
we i've used time boxing for
productivity and now this season's thing
it makes every like decision you're
making less heavy of a commit because
you're like it's okay yeah because
there's yeah there's beginnings and ends
and this season is gonna feel a little
different just like winter feels
different than summer that's how i use
it do you do you use it like that i just
noticed you said that phrase 100 yeah i
mean i i think about it in terms of
entrepreneurial seasons and i at least
for me might have been like five-year
chunks and so this is gonna be my fourth
season and they've roughly been about
the same length so i think that it
probably takes me like three ish years
to like really see something through and
then two years to figure out how i'm
going to transition from that thing or
realize or mod you know whatever that's
right it's kind of like a pe cycle
almost give us kind of like um give us
an example of normal like here's the
default way people are doing something
and then here's the rephrase of the
reframe that has better results um i
would love to get two minutes of
learning sales from alex sure so it's my
belief if you look at belford you look
at bradley you look at grant cardone
some of the big sales trainers that are
out there almost all of them invariably
have the same story which was i started
selling and was the best guy on the team
by a [ __ ] mile and then i tried to
figure out what i was doing and so i do
think that some people naturally based
on their childhood their upbringings
their whatever or just have a higher
proclivity for selling which yeah just a
gift of gab and and empathy yeah and i
think it carries over into how you
recruit for selling too because we built
a lot of sales teams and i actually have
a very short allowing for people to fail
at sales cycle probably much shorter
than most people and it's just because
i've never had a killer salesperson who
didn't do pretty well the first week and
so for me we you know we turn through
this quickly but as a result of that the
team is just killers and they know that
in terms of uh sales stuff i think
people don't know how people are really
freaked out about the idea of selling
and the front part of that is that i do
think that the number one predictor of
good sales is conviction fundamentally
you have one person who should believe
in something another person who does not
believe it yet and trust is the thing
that transfers that conviction so if
fundamentally there's the two things you
need you need trust and need conviction
most times sales people don't have 100
trust sorry 100 conviction and so the
also the idea of conviction as a binary
is false so it's not like i believe it
or i don't believe it is to what extent
do i believe right and so that's why
like in terms of if i want to improve a
sales team i can do the drills which we
do and that's like blocking tackling but
the thing that really juices the sales
team is hearing the testimonials of the
people that they sold last week and what
they're doing today and how their lives
have changed and so i noticed this
because on my sales teams when we were
in person whenever i did weigh out day
which is when everyone finished their
challenges and everybody was crying and
so excited i tried to stack as many
sales appointments as i could while
people were weighing out and during
those days we closed like 100 because
people were like dude how can you not
think this works it's right there and so
the thing is is like you can either
trick yourself into having the right
tone or you can train yourself and i
think that it's much easier to trick
yourself into it by just simply
believing because if you talk if you
truly believe in the product you will
talk about it differently and so in
terms of an understanding of selling if
you need to have conviction you need to
have trust trust is going to come from
expertise and some level of rapport
right i think that overarchingly to help
someone sell we just have to ask the
right questions to get someone to come
to the conclusion on their own and so
most sales conversations follow more or
less the same framework if you know what
you're doing otherwise people are just
chasing their tail and trying to chase a
prospect to an outcome that the prospect
doesn't know how like we've had this
conversation a hundred times they have
only had it once we should be the one
knowing how this conversation's supposed
to go right we should also come in with
a massive advantage to how to have this
conversation go the way we wanted to
because we do it on [ __ ] day right
and so big front end pieces is like why
are they there what's the problem what
have they done so far understanding
where they failed seeing why our product
is different from the things that they
failed asking for permission to explain
about the product explaining the product
not in any way based on features but
only based on the experiences that they
will have as a result of it and using
analogies to explain those experiences
and then having a close at the end which
the the tick tock i think that you he
references like a no base close and i
think a lot of natural sales people do
this anyways like if i want something i
might be like hey can you do this for me
i'm like hey would you mind and they say
no they don't i don't mind right like
it's natural communication dynamics that
most people who naturally know how to
persuade people or at least influence do
that on their own this is just
retroactively looking at it and saying
what did i do different like why is this
different in terms of like overcoming
because people are afraid of
confrontation right that's what they're
afraid of and so i believe that you can
sell without ever having confrontation
and you can do that with what i like to
call childlike curiosity and so if
someone says well my husband's not going
to approve that i'm like why wouldn't he
like huh that's so interesting tell me
more about that rather than like all
right let's like your husband's an
[ __ ] like that's not going to work
because in arguments no one wins right
and so you're like why why would he
think that because because i would think
that he wants what's best for you right
yeah he wants what's best does he know
you're struggling with this right now
well i mean yeah he knows i'm struggling
with it okay so he wants a specialty he
knows you're struggling with it so why
do you think he would be opposed of
solving something that you're currently
struggling with just so i understand
would he be happier if you continue to
struggle well no it's like well great
then would you be opposed to moving
forward today and that way and hey if
you go home to your husband and you make
a joke in the lightning scenario then
you close it right and so it's i think
child like curiosity is the immediate
that you have to train because people
get defensive so that is one thing that
like fighters talk about when they're in
the ring like in the beginning you
breathe in too much right i don't know
if like if you've been like sparring and
stuff like you breathe in you breathe
too much you hyperventilate and so the
guys who've done it enough they slow
down their breathing because when they
get things get intense they can slow it
down and so i think sales is a lot the
same way where you're like your
adrenaline kicks in start breathing
faster as fight or flight so you gotta
be able to slow down and be like huh
that's crazy i wouldn't have thought
that okay tell me more about that and
like now you're interested and then they
don't feel like you're combating them
they feel like you genuinely are
interested and want to help them which
is what you should be doing because you
should be
only if it makes sense you are full of
like interesting insights and like you
know a lot of [ __ ] and like you've
clearly packaged this in really easy to
understand ways it's almost exhausting
listening because it's like every it's
like when you read a really good
historical book or something it's like
every sentence is packed with a fact
yeah and it's like oh my gosh like i cuz
i got it i want to pay attention
i was like exhausting this is awesome
nation if you enjoyed that video smash
the subscribe button and hit the little
notification bell the reason for that is
because i don't actually have a cadence
for when i make these videos so if you
want to make sure you don't miss the
next one that comes out go subscribe
notify and i'll see you the next one bye